sur autorise à dessein regardez comment
où et comment ce camion a heurté la
passerelle pour piétons à la hauteur du
boulevard briand à repentigny
heureusement il n'y a pas de blessé
notre ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
autoroute 40 ça c'est la conséquence est
fermée en direction est entre le
boulevard briand et la rochelle ce qui
cause évidemment un important bouchon de
circulation et des 15h27 à montréal
imaginez le retour à la maison dans le
secteur
le camion qui transportait des grains de
maïs a percuté la structure de la
passerelle pour piétons sa benne était
on l'a vu sur les images précédemment
complètement ouverte
des équipes ont fini de ramasser les
grains qui se sont répandus sur la
chaussée regarder les images à nouveau
mais on ne sait toujours pas quand la
voix comme tel sera rouverte l'autoroute
a été fermée dans les deux directions
pendant environ une heure mais ces
derniers désormais uniquement dans la
direction est aussi fermée à l'accident
comme je disais c'est important de le
rappeler n'a fait aucun blessé
on y reviendra